มีวิธี
สวัสดีค่ะครูเรียมสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิง
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนครูเรียมวันนี้วันอะไร
คะวันนี้วันจันทร์ค่ะ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 6
เดือนอะไรคะเดือนมิถุนายน
ปีพตอะไรคะพ.ศ
ขอปีคศอะไรคะข้อ
2022 ค่ะ
ค่ะตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะแต่ตอนนี้
3:00 น
39 นาทีค่ะ
บ่าย 3 โมงแล้ว
ใช่ค่ะผู้หญิงผู้เรียนอะไรคะ
เรียนมีอะไรจะบอกคุยอีกหรือเปล่าค่ะก็ก็
คิดอยู่เพี้ยนที่จะบอกดีไหม
ทำไมอ่ะกูยังมีปัญหาอะไรหรอกขอมีปัญหา
อะไรหรือเปล่าคะไม่โอเคอะไรไหมไม่สบายใจ
อะไรหรือเปล่า
ไม่เป็นไรค่ะไม่เอาไม่เป็นไรค่ะผู้หญิงมี
มีมีเรื่องอะไรก็พูดได้นะ
ได้พูดได้
หรอไม่ไม่ไม่ต้องตามหนักไม่ต้องปักหนัก
พูดจะให้พูดได้ตอนนี้เรื่องปากหนักหรอ
ใต้ทรายคูเรียมเหมือนคนปากหนักเลยมีอะไร
ในไม่สบายใจไม่โอเคก็ไม่พูดไงเหมือนกลัว
ครูหญิงฟังแล้วเสียใจหรือเปล่าไม่เป็นไร
นะพูดได้ไม่ต้องปากนานงูยังว่าจะฝากผู้
หญิงเติมเงินโทรศัพท์ให้หน่อย
เท่าไหร่คะ
200 ค่ะคู่หญิง
ผู้หญิงมีอยู่ 100 บาทเองอ่ะกูเรียม
ไม่เป็นไร
ไม่พูดนะ
เตรียมขึ้นคนปากหนักหรอมีปัญหาอะไรมี
เรื่องถ้าใครแบบไม่มีเงินยังเงินไม่พอก็
ไม่บอกใครหรอ
ใช่ไม่บอกใครค่ะผู้หญิงเพราะว่าปากหนัก
ปุ๋ยจะไม่พูดมึงเป็นส่วนปากหนักนะเนี่ย
แล้วผู้หญิงล่ะคะผู้หญิงไม่ใช่คนปากหนัก
หรอ
อุ้ยผู้หญิงก็เป็นคนปากหนักนะเวลาที่มี
อะไรไม่โอเคหรือว่าไม่ไม่ไม่สบายใจ
ก็ไม่บอกใครมีสมมติว่าอ้ะวันนี้ใช่ไหมวัน
นี้เนี่ยต้องจ่ายเงินค่า Apartment แต่
ว่ายังกด atm ไม่ได้เลยบางทีแบบเอ้อไม่มี
เงินก็ไม่บอกคุณพ่อคุณแม่คนในครอบครัวก็
ไม่บอกก็กลับหนักไหมแบบนี้เรียกว่าปากเขา
เรียกว่าปากหนักค่ะผู้หญิงคนจริงผู้หญิง
จะโทรไปหาคุณพ่อโทรไปหาคุณแม่เราก็บอกก็
ได้
เรื่องที่ต้องจ่ายเงินค่าอพาร์ทเม้นท์
ใช่จากผู้หญิงรู้สึกแบบนี้
ไม่เอาอ่ะถ้าบอกคุณพ่อคุณแม่ถ้าคุณพ่อคุณ
แม่รู้ว่าครูหญิงไม่มีเงินเดี๋ยวคุณพ่อ
คุณแม่เนี่ยไม่สบายใจผู้หญิงไม่อยากให้
คุณพ่อคุณแม่คิดมากๆก็เลยไม่บอกดีกว่าไม่
เป็นไรมีหมู
อันนี้ก็ปากหนักนั้นครูเรียน
ใช่ถ้าเป็นครูเรียมสมุดว่าทุเรียนมไม่มี
เงินเงินไม่พอบอกคุณพ่อคุณแม่ไหม
ไม่ค่ะไม่บอก
อะไรอ่ะอาคูเรียมก็ปากหนัก
แล้วก็คิดว่าคนไทยหลายๆคนก็ปากหนักเหมือน
กันกับผู้ที่ทำนะ
ใช่ค่ะผู้หญิงก็คิดเหมือนกูเรียนนะเพราะ
ว่ารักหวังผู้คนไทยไม่ค่อยพูดมาใช่
คนไทยไม่ค่อยพูดหรือว่าครูหญิงถ้านะสมมติ
อันนี้ example นะคะนักเรียนถ้าครูหญิง
ไม่โอเคกับครูเรียวเนี้ยเดี๋ยวเราทำ
วีดีโอด้วยกันแล้วผู้หญิงคิดไม่โอเคเลย
อ่ะผู้เรียนสอนไม่โอเคแต่ครูหญิงไม่บอก
ครูเรียม
เวลาคูเรียมถามใช่ไหมว่าผู้หญิงครูเรียม
โอเคไหมสอนเป็นยังไงแล้วผู้หญิงไม่บอกไม่
พูด
คู่มือก็ไม่ชอบอันนี้ปากหนักไหมปากหนัก
อย่างนี้คือปากหนัก
[เพลง]
แล้วต้องคนน่ะปากหนักมากกว่านี้อีกนะคะ
ครูหญิงโง่ยังไงคะครูเรียมถ้าเกิดเดือนมี
เพื่อนที่แบบไม่ได้กันมันนานมากแล้วก็
เดินเดินเดินผ่านมาธรรมดาผู้หญิงเจอ
เพื่อนมีต้องทำยังไงคะ
เป้เป็นยังไงก็ต้องทักเพื่อนไงเอ้ยอิอิ
ไม่ได้เจอกันนั้นสบายดีไหมผู้หญิงก็ต้อง
ทักเพื่อนเนี่ยอ่ะกูเหลี่ยมแต่ว่าคนที่
ปากหนักเค้าจะไม่ทันนะเขาจะไม่แบบเขาจะ
ไม่สวัสดีนะเขาก็จะเดินผ่านไปแล้วก็ไม่
พูด
เหอะถ้าคุยหญิงเป็นเดิน Sky
นะคะแล้วก็แล้วก็เห็นครูเรียมใช่ไหมคะ
แล้วพิมพ์ก็ปะคูเรียมไม่เอาดีกว่าลมอัน
นี้ก็คือเป็นปัดนาคหรอๆอยู่ที่ว่าผู้หญิง
รู้สึกแบบไม่อยากพูดหรือว่าแบบรู้สึกไม่
อยากเจอถ้าเกิดไม่อยากเจอก็แบบเป็นอีก
เรื่องนึงแต่ถ้าเกิดแค่รู้สึกว่าไม่อยาก
พูดก็ปากหนัก
หือก็คือแบบ
ป่ามันเหมือนมันแบบมันอ้าวไม่ได้แล้วคือ
แบบสวัสดีเรียวไม่เอาไม่พูดดีกว่าไม่อยาก
พูด
อันนี้คือคนปากหนักหรอๆเพราะว่าบางทีเรา
เจอกันเราไม่ใช่แค่พูดว่าสวัสดีเราจะถาม
ด้วยทำอะไรหรอทำงานที่ไหนสบายดีไหมแบบ
พูห์ใต้ยาวมากแล้วคนที่ปากหนักเขาก็ไม่
ไม่ชอบพูด
เขาก็ไม่อยากคุยใช่ถ้าเราก็เลยบอกว่าเขา
เป็นคนปากหนัก
ถ้าเกิดเด็กที่เหมือนมันเตรียมยกกล่องมา
ใหญ่ๆลงน้ำหนักมากหนักมากแต่ผู้หญิงก็
นั่งเล่นโทรศัพท์อยู่
เตรียมก็กดผู้หญิงก็มองเฉยๆแต่ก็ไม่พูด
ไม่บอกผู้หญิงว่าผู้หญิงมาช่วยหน่อย
เหลี่ยมไม่พูดก็จะโอยโอยโอ๊ะๆมาอ๋อ
อันนี้ก็เป็นคนปากหนักหรอเวลาคนที่ไม่ขอ
ความช่วยเหลือใคร
ช่างตอนนี้ผู้หญิงต้องเป็นนะเวลาคุยหญิง
ยกของหนักๆอ่ะเวลาจะเข้าที่อพาร์ทเม้นท์
คอนโดใช่ไหมเขาจะมีรปภปิดๆยามเนี่ยยืน
อยู่เราบอกเขาได้นะพี่คะเปิดประตูให้
หน่อยมีแต่ผู้หญิงก็ไม่พูดนะ
ไม่ก็มีของแล้วก็แบบโอเคไม่เป็นไรตัวเอง
ใช้ตัวเองเออไม่อยากพูดอ่ะมันแบบมันไม่
อยากพูดอ่ะ
นั้นแหละ
เขาว่าอะไรอ้ะนักเรียนปากหนักเหมือนคนไทย
ไหมปากหนักเหมือนครูหญิงเหมือนผู้เรียม
ไหม
ได้นั่นสิไม่เห็นไม่ค่อยไหม
คิดว่าแบบคนไทยจะไม่ค่อยพูดเพราะว่ารู้
สึกเท่คนนี้จะโอเคไหมนะเขาจะช่วยเราหรือ
เปล่าเราก็เลยคิดไม่พูดไม่บอกดีกว่า
แป๊ะไชส์โจ๊กเอ่อคู่เรียมคูเรียม
อะไรนะคะถ้าเกิดนักเรียนเดินเดินแล้วก็
เห็นครูหญิงเห็นครูเรียมและนักเรียนจะ
ชาร์จมั้ยสวัสดีผู้หญิง
หรือว่าจะปากหนัก
ได้ไม่ได้อาจจะกลัวว่าเดี๋ยวพูดภาษาไทย
แล้วผู้หญิงฟังไม่เข้าใจหรือเปล่า
ก็เลยก็เลยไม่เพราะไม่พูดเปล่าแต่ว่าครู
เรียมครูเรียม B เพื่อนที่ปากหนักแนะนำ
แบบว่าจับเมื่อก่อนใช่ไหมเวลาคู่เรียน
เรียนหนังสือเนี้ยกูแล้วก็มีเพื่อนเพื่อน
เพื่อนๆเยอะๆใช่ไหมแล้วแบบอาจจะมีเพื่อน
ที่ที่ชอบใคร
แล้วไม่พูดไม่บอกว่าชอบอันนี้เราบอกเรา
เรียกว่าเป็นคนปากหนักไหมคะอันนี้ก็เรียก
ว่าปากหนังค่ะ
คนที่ไม่ออกพูดคิดคลิปๆรู้สึกรู้สึกรู้
สึกแต่ไม่พูดแอบ
ชอบผู้หญิงคนนั้นชอบผู้ชายคนนั้นมากๆรู้
สึกชอบมากๆคิดชอบนั่งหน้าแต่ว่าไม่พูด
พูดยุ้ย
อันนี้คิดว่าใครเนี่ยเป็นมากๆนะ
ใช่
ผู้หญิงแบบชอบใครแล้วก็ไม่พูด
ใช่ก็ไม่พูดหน้าพูดคุยหญิงเป็นเพื่อนเป็น
เพื่อนกับครูเรียมใช้เป็นเพื่อนกันแล้ว
ผู้หญิงชอบมิสเตอร์เอมากๆคู่เรียงผู้หญิง
ก็ไม่พูดไม่บอกว่าเลี้ยงเราชอบมิสเตอร์เอ
มากๆเลยคุยก็ไม่พูดไม่เอาถ้าเกิดผู้หญิง
พูดหรือว่าทุกคนก็จะรู้ว่าเรียงก็จะบอก
คือถ้า
สายหรืออ.บ้านฉางอย่างเงี้ยมิสเตอร์ก็จะ
บอกว่าบ๊ายบายนะหิงค์บ๊ายบายนะเทียมเราจะ
ไปอยู่ออสเตรเลียแล้ว
คุณก็จะดับพูดพูดพูดพูดพูดพูดไม่เอาไม่
พูดดีกว่านะผู้หญิงไทยจะเป็นนะแบบไม่กล้า
พูดเวลาที่เราชอบใครน้องก็ผู้หญิงใครจะ
เป็นคนปากหนักนักเรียนเพื่อนนักเรียนอาจ
จะแบบเออมีแฟนเป็นผู้หญิงไทยมีแฟนเป็นคน
ไทยอย่างเนี้ยก็อาจจะรู้สึกทำไมคนไทยไม่
พูดรักใช่มั้ยไม่บอกรักให้แบบรักนะไม่ไม่
พูดใช่ไหมเพราะว่าเรารู้สึกอ่ะ
ไม่เห็นต้องพูดเลย
ใช่เพราะว่าเราก็ไม่ค่อยได้ยินจากพ่อกับ
แม่นะเอาไว้รู้สึกว่าพูด
อ่ะ
หนูเหตุรถนักเรียนผู้เรียนม
แบบดูจากต่างประเทศที่เป็นชาวต่างชาติยัง
ก็จะรู้สึกว่าเขารู้สึกอะไรก็พูดออกมาพูด
ออกมาถุงอย่างแต่ว่าคนไทยอ่ะโอ๊ยปากน่ำ
ว่า
สร้อยคนไทยด้วยอะไม่พูดเลยไม่บอก
เขาคู่เตรียมมาหากูเนียมพูดหมายถือว่า
เป็นคนปากหนักเวลาชอบใครหรือว่าแบบ
ถ้ามีแฟนเนี่ยจะบอกไว้รักนะหวยปากหนักมาก
ๆก็เข้าใจแล้วไม่พูด
ไม่พูดค่ะผู้หญิงผู้หญิงพูดไหม
ทำไมเราถึงเป็นคนนั้นอ่ะ
จะขอก็เหมือนคุยเรียมบอกไงว่าคุณพ่อคุณ
แม่เราก็ไม่ได้พูดใช่ไหมว่ารักเราแต่คุณ
พ่อคุณแม่ก็ซื้ออาหารให้เรากินทำอาหารให้
เรากินเราก็รู้สึกว่าว่าคุณพ่อคุณแม่ทำ
อาหารให้เรากินก็รักเราไม่ต้องพูดเราก็
เลยคิดว่าก็ไม่ต้องพูดนะเราก็ทำอาหารซัก
ผ้าใช่ไหมโทรถาม
ส่งข้อความถึงบ้านล่างอะไรอย่างเงี้ยเรา
ก็คิดว่าก็โอเคแล้วเราก็เลยไม่พูดขึ้นมา
เพราะคนไทยอ่ะไม่ชอบพูด
ถ้าใช่แล้วบางทีแบบมีเรื่องอะไรที่แบบไม่
ดี
ก็ไม่พูด
ไม่พูดค่ะ
ใช่พูดว่าโอเคไม่เป็นไรถ้าคุยกับคุณเรียม
ทำไม
มีทุเรียนหน้าไม่ไม่ไม่ค่อยโอเคเลยอ่ะ
สบายดีใช่ไหมโอเคไหมออกก็องค์มีอะไรหรือ
เปล่าก็ก็โอเคค่ะ
OK นะไปไม่ได้มีอะไรใช่ไหม
ไม่มีโอเค
โอเคไหน
ฮักหนักมากนะคะแค่โอเคแล้วยังไม่พูดเลย
มีมีใครเปลี่ยนรู้จักที่เป็นแบบนี้ไหม
มันพูดอะไรเลยนะแค่พูดคำว่า
ใจปากหนักเว่อร์
โอเคโอเค
คนไทยทุกคนเป็น
นักเรียนมาคนอาจจะบอกท่านผู้หญิงไทยนี่
เลยผู้หญิงไทยปากหนามากใช่ทรายก็คิดว่า
ถ้านักเรียนมีแฟนแล้วก็นักเรียนกับแฟนแบบ
ว่าทำไมจำวันเกิดไม่ได้แล้วแฟนโกรธใช่ไหม
แฟนโกรธที่ว่าผู้หญิงทุกประเทศเหมือนกัน
นะเวลาถามเป็นอะไรเป็นอะไรผู้หญิงก็จะแบบ
เหมือนคุณเหลี่ยมกินเหล้าอีกคนปากหนัก
เหมือนกัน
อาบนานผู้ชายก็มีนะปากหนักก็แบบชอบก็ไม่
บอกรักก็ไม่บอก
[เพลง]
ใช่ค่ะเรายิ่งแบบว่าถ้าผู้ชายเขามีมีแบบ
อะไร
สมมติว่าที่ทำงานไม่โอเคสมัยหรือว่าแบบ
ไม่สบายอย่างเงี้ยผู้ชายบางครั้งก็ไม่บอก
นะว่าผู้ชายคิดและก็ผู้ชายต้องแข็งแรง
สมัยต้องแข็งแรงถ้าบอกก็ไม่โอเคผู้ชายก็
ปากหนักนะบางครั้งเนี่ยไม่สบายจนไม่สบาย
มากๆอ่ะถึงบอกว่าฮัลโหล
เหลี่ยมก็ไม่บอกเราบางครั้งพูด
ไม่บอกค่ะแบบปวดหัวนิดหน่อยปวดท้องนิด
หน่อยเนี่ยไม่บอกแต่พอปวดท้อง 1 วัน 2  3
วันแบบไม่โอเคแล้วต้องไปโรงพยาบาลบาง
ครั้งผู้ชายถึงบอกว่าผู้ชายคิดต้องแข็ง
แรงไงก็จะปากหนักบางเรื่องเนี่ยมากกว่า
ผู้หญิง
บางทีรู้สึกเสียใจ
ก็ไม่บอก
ไม่ใช่ผู้ชายพูดไม่ได้ใช่ไหม
จริงเรางานของผู้ชายแล้วก็ผู้หญิงก็มี
เรื่องที่ปากหนักก็เหมือนกัน
[เพลง]
ถ่ายแต่อาจจะเป็นคนละเรื่องกันเนาะ
ถ้าถ้าผู้ชายเสื้อไหมต้องขอให้ครูเรียม
ช่วยแบบเรี่ยมช่วยผมหน่อยตอนนี้ที่บ้านผม
ไม่เคเลยเตรียมช่วยได้ไหมบางครั้งผู้ชาย
เนี่ยไม่พูดเธอไม่บอกไม่ขอความช่วยเหลือ
[เพลง]
ก็น่าจะจริงเพราะว่าเหลี่ยมก็ไม่ค่อยได้
ยินผู้ชายมาบอกให้ช่วยหน่อย
น้อยมา
[เพลง]
ใช่ค่ะเพราะผู้ชายไทยก็จะปากหนักเวลาที่
ต้องขอให้โคนแหละช่วยเราเขาจะรู้สึกแบบมี
ไม่ได้นะผมเป็นผู้ชายในก็จะปัดน่ะเรื่อง
นี้มากๆผู้หญิงอาจจะน้อยกว่าหรือ
ไม่ใช่
บางเรื่องนะบางเรื่องก็ปากก็
แล้วแต่คนด้วยเนาะแล้วแต่คนด้วยนะคะๆๆ
ก็คิดว่ามันก็ก็อาจจะมีบางเรื่องที่นัก
เรียนก็ปากหนักเหมือนกันที่ไม่ยอมผู้หญิง
ชายคะถ้านักเรียนมีเรื่องที่นักเรียนแบบ
ไม่พูดเป็นเรื่องที่นักเรียนกับปากหนักจะ
ก็คอมเม้นท์บอกเขาได้เนาะใส่เนี่ยบอกว่า
ขนาดพูดยังไม่พูดเลย
เล่นหรอก็กดไลค์ไงกดไลค์เล่นรู้จะได้รู้
ว่ามีเรื่องอะไร
นักเรียนบอกว่ามือก็หนักกดไลค์ให้
ได้
ใครปากหนักกดไลค์มาค่ะเรียนจะได้รู้ว่ามี
คนต่อไปค่ะก็เยอะหรือเปล่า
เนาะชายค่ะแล้วแต่ว่า
วีดีโออีกวันนี้หมดเวลาแล้วใช่ไหมคะคุณ
เรียมใช่ค่ะเดี๋ยวเราต้องเจอกันในคิดค่ะ
แล้วค่ะครูหญิง
ชลันก็เดี๋ยวเจอกันในคลิปต่อไปเนาะส่วน
วีดีโอนี้ผู้หญิงกับผู้เรียนก็ไปก่อนนะคะ
สวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะคุณผู้หญิงสวัสดีค่ะ
นักเรียนไม่ว่าสวัสดีค่ะอ่ะ